like a backup goalie in hockey the
bluewater bridge has suddenly been
called into action because a couple of
hours away in windsor protesters are
still not letting trucks cross the much
larger ambassador bridge into canada
this man who calls himself greg defends
the ongoing blockade why do i think i
have the right why does any protester
think he has the right to do anything
for three days shipments have been
diverted and slowed down frustrating
many driving those delayed rigs and
infuriating industries that count on
speedy deliveries it's a huge challenge
for all the industries involved for all
the employees involved and of course for
you know just the flow of goods to final
citizens to consumers it's it's just um
it's staggering actually the auto
industry is especially dependent on
those shipments and thousands of jobs it
is breathlessly stupid
for a group that wants to
inspire
people to join their movement
to put those same people out of work and
now and here we are formally requesting
additional resources windsor's mayor is
asking for federal and provincial help
including more police officers is there
a timeline to get this resolved
again today tomorrow situation unfolds
we're not going to discuss our
operational plans public safety is the
number one priority and we're looking to
restore traffic flow in the area as
pressure to shut down this protest and
reopen the bridge to incoming trucks
intensifies such action may inflame the
situation
and certainly cause more folks to come
here and add to the protest and we don't
want to risk additional conflict back at
the protest i asked greg about that if
they decide to uh to break this up what
are you guys going to do
there'll be some resistance just like
black lives matter resists nothing's
likely to change in windsor until that
city gets the support it's looking for
near here there was a brief protest but
they moved on the unofficial concern a
second block bridge because as difficult
as this situation is that would be
significantly worse
donna
all right shawn o'shea in point edward
ontario thank you